Cena would see as corrupt Cena know what
beauty see where it lies he may have
died around 400 years ago but
Shakespeare could soon be in the charts
lyrics by the bard who's regarded as one
of the greatest writers of all time have
now been put to music and if Shakespeare
was alive today he would have been the
one signing this contract for an album
of love songs based on his sonnets
they're so perfect they're so beautiful
but they they say what we all what
people felt then what we feel now about
love I mean when you first see someone
that you fall in love with and you say
you know I say to you Lucy shall I
compare thee to a summers day thou art
more lovely what could be more lovely
than a summer's day see what you don't
get a better writer for lyrics no
disrespect to any other writers in the
world but Shakespeare and so we have
probably the most beautiful words ever
written about love just as a starting
point and we took them and hopefully we
paid homage to them with what we did
give them they've used Shakespeare's
timeless lyrics with Elizabeth and
instruments giving the tracks a modern
and unique sound sure
so to our minutes we wanted to have
colors from the time of Shakespeare but
used them in a contemporary way to kind
of merge the two worlds and it was a
real challenge to make that happen
Shannon but for the producer who
discovered pop princess pixie lott this
is something of a gamble what caught my
imagination was the whole concept of it
taking the solids and putting them to
music in a modern style you know now
we've got to convert that to the
audience and so far I think we're doing
it the hope is this record not only
charts but is critically acclaimed
meaning we could see the bard winning an
Ivor Novello or a brit awards Lucy
Cotter Sky News
you